el valle de napa corazón de la región
vinícola por excelencia de california
también está siendo devorado por los
incendios las llamas han consumido más
de 4.500 hectáreas de los condados de
napa y sonoma donde se han alcanzado los
39 grados centígrados y vientos de 80
kilómetros por hora en los últimos días
miles de vecinos se tuvieron que marchar
de sus casas con urgencia y estuvo muy
cerca el tráfico estaba congestionado
fue una locura salir de aquí luego una
vez pude regresar fue un alivio ver que
algunas de nuestras cosas todavía
estaban aquí pero fue una noche
aterradora fue una locura
las imágenes tomadas por los ciudadanos
durante su vida en automóvil muestran la
gravedad del momento las llamas
bordeaban la carretera que utilizaron
para escapar durante el día los focos
llegaron hasta los suburbios de santa
rosa la principal ciudad afectada en
total hasta 2.200 viviendas se
calcinaron por los incendios se reforman
mi casa hasta un cuarto de milla de la
carretera en juego el montón road y el
incendio estaba a unos 100 metros de mi
casa así que ahora mismo estamos
esperando que los bomberos puedan ganar
la batalla la costa oeste de eeuu
atraviesa la peor oleada de incendios de
su historia que hasta el momento se
estima que ha terminado con la vida de
al menos 38 personas y ha carbonizado
más de 2,6 millones de hectáreas